♪♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WELCOME.
OUR PROPHETS TOLD OF A SAVIOR.
HE WOULD ARRIVE FROM ANOTHER
LAND TO
FREE OUR WORLD FROM THE GRIP OF
DARKNESS.
WHAT IS YOUR BIRTH NAME?
>> CHAD.
>> THE DARK LORD AZERHAN AND HIS
ARMY OF SHADOWS HAS ENTOMBED OUR
WORLD IN ICE AND SNOW.
>> ONLY YOU CAN DEFEAT HIM,
CHAD.
>> OKAY.
>> WE MUST INFORM THE QUEEN OF
YOUR ARRIVAL.
>> NO NEED.
I FELT HIS PRESENCE.
I AM QUEEN CHRYSALIS, RULER OF
ASSYRIA AND THE NINE RIVERS FROM
STARK TO EVERSEED.
>> OKAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THESE
MEADOWS BLOOMED.
AND THERE IS HOPE THAT THEY MAY
BLOOM AGAIN, FOR TODAY MARKS
YOUR COMING.
>> HA, HA, COMING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO SAYS THE PROPHECY.
>> IN UNISON: SO SAYS THE
PROPHECY.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT YOU MUST UNDERTAKE A
DANGEROUS JOURNEY.
YOU MAY RETURN TO YOUR WORLD AT
ANY TIME IF YOU DESIRE.
THE CHOICE IS YOURS.
BUT BE WARNED.
>> HE LEFT.
>> WHAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
GO.
>> MY LIEGE.
>> YES.
>> CHAD, WHY DID YOU LEAVE?
>> I WAS BORED.
>> CAN YOU COME BACK FOR A
MOMENT?
WE WEREN'T DONE.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU CHAD.
YOU HAVE CHOSEN TO FOLLOW YOUR
DESTINY.
>> FIRST YOU MUST CLIMB THE
MOUNTAIN OF DESPAIR.
>> OKAY.
>> AND THEN FORD THE RIVER OF
FLAME.
>> OKAY.
>> AND SURVIVE THE FOREST OF
TRANSLUCENT TRANSGRESSIONS.
>> AND AFTER THE VEIL OF EVIL IS
LIFTED,
YOU WILL BECOME KING AND I WILL
GIFT WITH YOU MY VIRGINITY.
>> DOH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AFTER YOUR JOURNEY.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> TO AID YOU ON THIS QUEST, WE
GIVE YOU THESE ITEMS.
>> FROM THE ORDER OF THE
CENTAURI, I PRESENT YOU WITH
THIS MAP TO GUIDE YOU.
THOUSANDS OF MY KIND DIED BEYOND
THE MOUNTAINS TO CREATE IT.
MAY THEY REST WITH THE GODS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> FROM THE KINGDOM OF DWARVES,
I GIVE YOU THE CRYSTAL OF
GUMLIGIN TO LIGHT YOUR PATH.
>> GAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND FROM THE ELVEN COUNCIL,
THE SWORD OF THE GREAT WARRIOR,
ASHTON.
>> SAFE TRAVELS, YOUNG WARRIOR.
MAY THE GREAT GODS BLESS YOU.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪
>> THAT BOY IS OUR LAST HOPE.
>> I DO NOT SEE A BOY.
I SEE A WARRIOR.
>> HA HA, LOOK.
>> IT'S LIKE HIS SWORD IS HIS
PENIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
VERY CLEVER.
>> OKAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]